hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm going to show
you why you don't put green beans in a
fire now this is an opportunity for you
to learn a life's lesson the easy way
learn from my mistakes so I've got my
Forge here got a can of green beans I'm
gonna see what's happening
[Applause]
yeah
holy crap that was a lot bigger than I
expected
yeah so life lesson there
don't put green beans in a fire so it
kind of explodes like crazy everywhere
so I got all the fire out and I got to
clean up all the siding get all the
green beans off there I got to see if I
can get the charcoal stains that are
embedded in my siding out as well so
anyway thanks for watching and remember
don't put green beans in the campfire